Britain's iconic red squirrel is in
trouble the problem the invasive eastern
gray squirrel
brought to England from North America
about a hundred and forty years ago
wealthy collectors in the 19th century
like to keep gray squirrels as pets
or release them onto their estates as
kind of a living lawn ornament in fact
there's genetic evidence that all of the
grey squirrels and ions are descended
from six pairs sent as a wedding gift
the grey squirrel is bad news for the
native red squirrels because they
out-compete them for food and habitat
worst of all grave carry a virus called
squirrel pox it doesn't harm the grey
squirrels or people for that matter but
it is deadly to the race so many
conservation groups working to save the
red squirrel have had some successes
grey squirrels have been eradicated from
the Isle of Anglesey it took eighteen
years but now the islands red squirrels
are on the rebound and there is hope
that nature may help the pine marten a
relative of weasels is a native predator
scientists in Ireland have noticed an
intriguing pattern where pine martens
show up to the population of grey
squirrels declines and red squirrels
start to recover it may be that red
squirrels which evolved with the pine
marten are better able to escape these
tree climbing predators the future of
the red squirrel is looking brighter in
the UK but there's still much to be done
the lesson for other countries is to
prevent gray squirrels from arriving at
all or getting rid of them as quickly as
possible and to definitely not give them
as wedding presents